[Musique]
salut tout le monde
alors me revoilà assez vite puisque
alireza firoud déjà rencontre une
nouvelle fois maxime vachier lagrave
cette fois ci en finale du title tuesday
les deux hommes ont fait nul dans la
première partie
maxime avait les noirs et donc on se
retrouve dans le match retour maximal et
pièces blanches c'est du 3 + 1 et donc
en cas de victoire d'un des deux hommes
il remporte le title de mardi dernier à
noter qu on continue les formats courts
entre guillemets express sur czech comme
on se lance tout de suite ces quatre
joué par maxime donc anglaise entre
guillemets cavaliers f6 cavaliers f3e 6
g 3d 5-fu jets d'oeuf ou e7 petit rock
petit rock et d4 donc on est parti avec
ses 4 une invitation à jouer une
anglaise finalement et par transposition
on se retrouve dans une ouverture
catalan
ici les noirs jouent dépensé 4 donc ali
reza qui prend le pion non défendu et
maxime qui joue dame ces deux avec
l'idée de le récupérer tout simplement
alors on a vu déjà sur la chaîne big
prime une très belle partie après b 5
grilles tchouk naka dans un grand prix
l'an dernier je vous invite à la re voir
si ça vous intéresse mais dans cette
partie alireza joue le typique à 6 alors
l'idée de à 6 c'est que si on joue comme
français 4 qui est très théorique 1 il
rejoue et b5
comme ça ils gagnent un tempo sur la
dame ce qui lui permet de ne pas se
prendre une découverte sur la tour
la dame bouge et il joue fougue et 7
pour m le fou en vis-à-vis
donc ça c'est l'idée sur a6 après dame
france et 4 mais maxime a continué par à
4 quillan aussi un coût très théorique
avec l'idée de jouer d'armes français 4
mai de ne pas laisser le temps de faire
b5 pour gagner le tempo sur la dame et
évitez donc les découvertes sur quoi les
résas jouer c5 ou très logique aussi
alors le coup le plus typique c'est fou
ce 17 avec l'idée sur dame français
cadre de mettre le fou en c6 qui sera
bien placé sur la grande diagonale mais
ces 5
après à 4 va aussi tout à fait puisque
on veut retrouver une structure de pions
plus ou moins symétrique en échangeant
un pion de l'ale contre un pion central
maxime qui fait cet échange sur ces 5
puis en français 5 vous prend ses 5es
dame prend ses quatre attaques le fou et
récupère le pion alors ici on va faire
une toute petite pause pour voir que la
structure finalement les pions se font
tous face 1 2 pions aal.l dames et cap
sion allait là allaient droit qui sont
sur les mêmes colonnes
mais le défaut des noirs dans cette
position c'est le fou c8 qui a du mal à
se développer on voit que pour faire re
5 et se développer de manière naturelle
oui ça va être compliqué parce que la
case de 5 elle est très bien contrôlé et
du coup il va falloir partir vers
bessette mais on va peut-être avoir un
petit moment difficile puisqu'on va se
retrouver dans le viseur du fou deux
cases blanches
ils jouent cependant b6 et maxime
profite pas de cave a lieu cinq pour
faire une découverte donc il n'a pas
joué ce coup parce qu'après tour à 7,7
tour finalement les pas si mal placé
elle permet de protéger la case bessette
pour jouer du fou bessette mais aussi
sept tours elle pourra venir verser 7
ouvert 17 pour ce doublé avec une dame
avec une tour donc elle paraît un peu
bizarre en assène t elle les uns
d'ailleurs mais là quand même l'idée de
revenir et de faire quelque chose de
dassin assez mal un sou de revenir ce
double évident si on fait pour ces huit
tours c'est cette aura des tours doublé
sur ces et on sera très content donc
maxime qui sur b si je vous fous g5 il
le laisse se développer avec le foufou
17 cavaliers c3 donc maxime se développe
aussi sort ses pièces cavale et b17 et
tous rêvent d un donc les joueurs ont
fini leur développement on voit encore
une petite avance pour maxime puisqu'il
a déjà sorti la tour en face de la dame
et que saddam c4 on va voir pourra
naviguer vers le roi adverse tour c'est
il se met en face de la dame aussi
menace ouvrant à f/2 échec donc il est
temps de partir et maxime qui s'en va
donc vers h4 alors ici il a joué dames
cette fille rouge alors l'ordi propose
un coup comme dame évite par exemple
aussi pour sortir du clivage dames c'est
tout à fait jouable
un autre jeu juste montrer comme ça
c'était tour c'est celle qu'on a parlé
tour à sept pour jouer éventuellement
damas huit et venir faire 1-1 se mettre
sur cette grande diagonale faire un
clouage et peut-être par la suite tours
fc 8 pour doubler avec les tours voilà
ce soit ce sont des idées
il a joué dams est pourquoi pas et
maxime qui jouent eux 4 et donc qui se
prépare à jouer eux cinq pour jouer sur
ce clou âge alors allié réseau aurait pu
jouer tous rêvent dé 8
parce que sur re5 avait des rendre
compliqué à base d'oeuf ou pour un f3 et
donc les blancs ban arrivé via des pions
prend un f6 puis on reprend ici c'était
vraiment un peu longue mais mais les
blancs réussissent pas à gagner de 2
pièces et donc tous rêvent des huit
étaient jouables et ça aurait évité de
qui se passe ce qui s'est passé dans la
partie donc fois c'est juste mais bon le
5 ça fait peur c'est du blitz faut
calculer il a décidé de jouer non pas
tous rêvent dé 8 mai h6 pour chasser le
fou est pas avoir à s'embêter à calculer
des variantes compliqué mais maxime
kidder jouer assez vite dans cette
partie un peu comme dans la partie de ce
battle contre les bras prend 3 secondes
et balance bible prend 17 qu'il avait
prévu à l'avance donc il dévie la dame
pour pouvoir reprendre un f6 à l'heure à
noter que sur puis on prend g5 si on
veut pas se prendre le chou progressiste
on le sait depuis on prend h4 hier le
fou quand bessette qui se retrouvent en
prise à la fin donc dame prend 17 joué
par ali reza foot pro f 6 g prend f6
faut bien récupérer la pièce et dame
prend h6 donc maxime qui récupère déjà
un pion et qui a des idées de dames
prices puis de cavaliers g5 qui arrive
de ramener sa tour en d1 et ma foi
d'attaquer ce roi faible en g8
alors la meilleure défense d'après leur
dit c'est assez instructif là encore
c'est jouer tous rêvent des huit dames
problème si c'est fois fuite pour
ramener le fou à grandes enjambées et se
dire qu'une fois que le fou et angers 7
il est très difficile de mater puisqu'on
a un genre de fille en quête au même si
on a perdu les les deux pions et que
après kg 5
quand on fera dès jeudi un coup le land
adams est quand on fera damage 7,3 et
fuite
on n'arrive pas à mater parce qu'on
n'arrive pas à rentrer sur sur quatre
mois donc après dame prend 1,6
intéressant quand même d'un point de vue
pédagogique tout rêve des huit fois
fuite ça peut être un réflexe de ramener
rapidement se fout en défense dans la
partie la jouer dames 7 pour conserver
le pion f6 maxime qui envoie e5 donc
avec l'idée que sur france 3 pour
supprimer un attaquant va hélas si on
prend un f6 et il va mater
angers7 donc eu cinq provoque puis on
prend 2,5 et maintenant cavalier g5
maxime menace de nouveau damage set elle
n'a pas le temps de faire tous rêvent dé
8 tamas 7,3 et fuite d'un match 8 matchs
donc sur cavaliers g5 il faut absolument
défendre la case h7 c'est chose faite
par ali reza après f6 donc il défend
latéralement h7 il attaque le cavalier
d'alger six échecs roi h 8 et maintenant
vous prendre bessette là encore variante
très fort c'est on n'a pas le temps de
prendre le cavalier puisque la tour est
en prise donc ali reza qui reprend le
fou et maxime qui encaisse le pion e6
alors ici à noter qu'un coup comme d'un
match 7 pas être intéressant pour forcer
quelque part les changes des dames et
jouer cette finale avec un pion de moins
donc ça peut être parfois une idée en
blitz pour essayer de sauver quand on
prend une grosse attaque de rendre du
matériel et de redonner le matériel et
ou avec une option de moins mais on face
à maxime on comprend qu'il soit pas
rentré dedans donc sur sky prend aussi
s'il veut garder le matériel il fait
tour eiffe cette maxime qui joue damas
six échecs
donc là y'a pas tous rage satya dame
prend m6 dont croix j'évite forcé dame
g6 roi je suis une petite répétition et
maintenant cavalier e 4 ramène une
nouvelle pièce en attaque on menace
cavaliers pro f 6 et damas si cela qui
serait qui ferait vraiment très mal avec
le dio dame cavaliers qui contrôlerait
absolument toutes les cases d'un prend
bon on apprend que quatre façons ses
protégés mais gère la tour eiffel sete
en plus et en l'air donc il a joué dames
2e set il s'en prend aux cavaliers e6
est ici maxime va rater une super
tactique
vous pouvez mettre sur pause pour
chercher elle est vraiment pas facile il
aurait pu jouer cavalier six français
cinq est sûre pions prince et cinq
cavaliers des six vraiment très
esthétique menace les deux tours
fourchette donc et sur d'arbres en d6
dame prend f7 avec une position
absolument écrasante puisque le roi noir
et en plus en grand danger
il l'a pas vu et mais elle est vraiment
dur à voir il a fait d'armes à 5 tours
h7 et dames f5 et la maintenance et
alireza qui va rater une super pratique
franchement vraiment dur à voir au ciné
je vous montre parce que très jolie est
ici un coût mais vraiment alors là
incroyable cette tactique il avait ici
avec les noirs le coup-franc --les deux
échecs emprise trois fois
mais ya pas de bonnes prises vont déjà
sur dame prend il ya dame progressis
donc ça c'est facile de le voir sur fou
prend cavaliers prend le problème c'est
qu'ils à tour ses six ça c'est vraiment
dur à voir et le cavalier t'enfermer
rate cases d'accord donc cavalier perdu
et il n'y a plus le cavalier prend un f6
1 parce que tout à l'heure à vrai dire
si on faisait un tour c6 le problème
c'est qu'il y avait éventuellement mêmes
maps cavaliers français
cavalli six français cinq pardon en
premier et qu'elle était en prise mais
prend ses 5es tour des uns et la tour va
rentrer le long de la colonne des c'est
bien pour les blancs même si pas fini
mais du coup et en plus à des vies donc
les toutes les variantes ya plus de
cavaliers prend et on aura le temps de
prendre le cavalier donc fou prend un f2
et sur roy prend il y a tous reprochent
de l'échec donc menace le roi roger 1 et
tour cessé de et là du coup les noirs
ont le temps de deux sur cavaliers pros
f6 de jouer échec échec et de récupérer
les deux cavaliers donc fou prend avec
deux échecs dans cette position-là sur
la prise du cavalier tour ses six sur la
prise de la dame dame prend aussi sur la
prise du roi pour proche d'eux donc très
très très jolie variante ici bon sur
dame f5
les noirs ont joué tour g8 donc
il n'a pas vu le fou prend f2 mais
maintenant il ya tout un tas de
problèmes dont dame price is donc je
veux dont vous parlez enfin la prise du
cavalier en effet six ans je vous parle
avant qu'un énorme problème d'un bref si
sa ket problème si on est là et là c'est
tout de suite finie puisque à une
fourchette à effet fou prend un air deux
échecs pour réussir à jouer sur roy
prend un tour et vii pour jouer sur le
clouage donc pour ne pas perdre de
matériel et même avoir une bonne
position mais maxime bien évidemment
donc la vue sur foot pro f2i la 3g 2 les
noirs ont toujours à faire face à cette
fourchette
il a joué tour j'ai six cavaliers prend
à vii tour prend aussi ses cavaliers g5
et là en suisse il a pas de bol alireza
bon déjà il est malin parce que
d'options pas scellier et la finale est
forte pour les blancs mais en plus il a
le fou emprise et à s'y fait tous réussi
six as cavalier e 4 donc qui menace la
tour et le fou donc y perdrait le fou
donc il est obligé de faire tourner et 6
pour suroît prend un f2 avoir tout
reprend g5
mais maintenant il ya cavaliers f7 3g
sept cavaliers prend 2,5 et à maxime à
deux pions passé lié à l'est le roi et
ça pour un joueur du calibre de maxime
c'est vraiment très simple à gagner et
donc maxime qui va remporter le title
tune et je laisse les derniers coups se
jouer à l'écran donc en finissant la
vidéo est donc un grand bravo à maxime
qui remporte le title tuesday énorme
tournoi de sa part il avait remporté la
phase du système suisse et il a il a
gagné donc la phase finale à huit
j'espère que ce petit format de vidéo
express vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
laisser un pouce bleu et un commentaire
et on se retrouve très bientôt
ciao ciao
où est le